o pessoal bem 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma final foi o papel que dispara
cinco bares iminente para cinco mas se
vocês quiserem por mais podem aqui é só
aumentar o tamanho do credor e não pude
mais cinco porque esteticamente não fica
pois bonito
ok então eu vou fazer uns testes mas
pronto e vou explicar como é que vocês
conseguem separar como eu ou seja
olhando no tubo e vamos tentar filtrar
eu faço assim o posiciona no lugar não
consigo segurar banho na equipa e
disparar para frente e óleo onde e
quando a bola do teu
depois de ver onde é que ela bateu e o
justo para tucano cima ou seja aquela
parte da mira para coincidir com o lugar
do disparo aqui frontera a partir desse
momento sempre parar aquela distância
vai acertar onde estiver o olhar pelo
tubinho vocês podem ver armas ficou
muito bonita e agora eu vou ensinar como
fazê-la pasta-base primeira coisa tem
que ir lá no folha como se fosse uma
rifa é que ela das feiras
caso você não consiga fazer isso irá
entrevistar um link de inscrição onde
ensina a fazer isso mais devagar passo a
passo
depois tem que rolar uma folha volta do
modo fazer um tubinho justo em tudo e
prendam com fita
afinal é no pedaço grande passo por um
lado a outro referendo deste modo vai
ficar tudo leasing para fazer uma rifa
mas mais cni vai gente o trai modo a
fazer um triângulo e quando abri o
triângulo forma um quadrado e que é o
mesmo desta vez só com tamanho folha
mais que eu vou começar a fazer
empunhadura da região e as medidas têm
um pedaço de docente entre os dois times
com cinco sentidos
hoje só colar deste modo os mais
pequeninos vão diretamente para trás
ou seja cada segmento vai gerar muito
mais para trás do currículo por cima e
agora eu vou juntar estas duas listas
dos livros para fazer a crônica da saída
agora se você quiser fazer uma campanha
maior vocês podem usar o papel de jornal
até aí só fazer a mesma coisa do que fez
com jornal e assim não conseguir fazer
no crânio bem maior
naquela partida eu vou usar cola quente
vocês podem usar outras escolas só que
não fica tão bairro fica tão resistente
para fazer para te dunga que vai joão vi
que o encaixe no do vinho e isso aí o
ligeiramente risco para fora do brasil
moda fazer mais ou menos um em que uma
parte fica maior que a outra
então agora vamos fazer este design no
pedaço de cartão e usei uma caixa de
cereais é esse que nem é muito grosso
nem muito fina aí que você acha da
música e fazer esta espécie de caixa de
fósforos
agora se vocês não precisam mais níveis
e eu vou correr algumas terapias no
facebook para vos orientar ok e agora e
vou encaixar esta parte da caixa de
fósforos
num mundo os tubinhos poucos
vejam que há uma distância de 9
centímetros
depois a partir daí a equipe vão
instalar-se caixa aqui e abertura é uma
coisa muito importante quando vocês
forem colar à caixa ao tubo tem que
encaixar dentro uma rifa isso porque por
aqui
calcular em caixa e não entrar lá dentro
e não obstrua a passagem e assim se
vocês quiserem falar dentro vai ficar
tudo muito livro cair não vai ver nada
obstruir a passagem das balas depois com
cuidado para assegurar para que o colar
e um pedacinho pequenino que vai me
ajudar ali a forçar a conexão entre as
duas partes é que o guarda mata ninguém
alguém disse o agora cola no carregador
veicular e assim deixar o youtube vai
ficar mais resistente e punham cola nas
extremidades do sul
um momento que estou fazer é mais uma
questão de resistência
isto não tem nada lá dentro para
conseguir encaixar aquela base do normal
agora eu vou contornará para imprimir
dura dar uma volta
a resistência vai aumentar
substancialmente quando vocês não darem
a volta é só colar do sinpro assim com
muita calma
e vamos acreditar que algo do gênero
visto pronto com eles a queridinha para
a caixa e também vai estar lá no
facebook a imagem acho eu não me engano
não têm certeza terei fotografias não
ter um screenshot deixar lá é e esta
parte porque para empurrar os bairros
para entrarem dentro do cano da arma cai
agora eu fiz aquela para eu preciso dar
um pouco de volume então fiz esta lei
faz aqui bem pequenininhas e vou colar
ali nessas partes cortar primário
escolar
se vocês quiserem podem levar um pedaço
livro o cartão grosso podem substituir
nessa partida e que dá um pulinho
trabalha 41 salvar que é o cartão que
tem duas camadas corta um pedaço mais ou
menos que o tamanho e pronto
assim em pouco tempo e agora estou fazer
a parte do apoio na parte da frente na
esquerda é bastante simples é só
encaixar duas rifas em que uma grande e
outra e mais pequenina aprendam com fita
tem que optar bem para casa muito
entretanto as duas partes que só haverá
30 pois é fácil ajustar já encaixou
eu vou fazer o pistão que estão tanto
que vai ficar com o papel de empurrar as
balas
veja aqui o braille uma pequena parte e
vou encaixar dois elásticos esse larsson
bastante forte
agora se o sócio não foram vocês podem
acrescentar mais elástico só que aí tem
que jogar com a existência da arma barra
força e vejam até onde é que eu vou
cortar mas nunca achei aquela pequena
parte ali atrás na parte trabalha e onde
começa o carregador a 'marca' e cortei e
agora vou fazer a partir da ótica
o tema foi o maior lobby isso para ter
bastante opcional vocês podem usar a
vossa criatividade mais aqui
assim mais do título de demonstração
era uma coisa que vocês devem pensar em
portugal que estas coisas que eu vou
fazer aqui conquistei um todo assim indo
bem pequenininho
vamos lá no centro
eu escutei dois outros filmes de lado
para conseguir movimentar lá é
movimentar esta parte consegue ajustar
voz e agora tem que juntar a para o de
mira ao corpo da arma salvar uma rifa e
mudar nesta coisa assim maio para o
formato do varjão que permite a
mobilidade dessa partida
pois é só por cole e colar
mas se vocês forem crianças é e quando
forem usar é utilizado essas coisas
peçam ajuda o doc certeza que elas não
se importar com isso é uma coisa muito
importante usar aqui uma cola rápida uma
super cola propor nestas partes aqui e
isso vai diminuir o atrito e vai
aumentar muito mas mesmo muito é a
existência da arma nuclear se vocês não
usarem uma cola uma super cola avançar
mas não vai aguentar muito provavelmente
não vai conseguir parar dado o trânsito
entre o papel cair pronto como é que
vocês usem uma cola rápida tanto faz o
importante é que seja rápido e fica
assim tipo acho que quando elas em ok
vocês convém também limpar em bairros
para que não fica assim em conta dentro
do dos tubos e sim pois não deixa cheiro
o questão também têm que foi nesta parte
do que está agora só falta mesmo fazer
as balas que as balas são bastante
simples é só vocês medida de um lado uma
diferença é maior
do outro lado uma mais pequenina e
enrolando a parte maior para a parte
mais fina e no final é só aprender com
fita eu fiz modo em que a parte maior da
bala de revólver
seja do tamanho do carregador e para a
china por manter aí 10 27 anos mas a
mídia não não lembro já não lembro bem
de qualquer coisa assim do gênero
agora é só passar o elástico por onde
ocupa sair modo que não interfere com a
quarta figura nessa parte para empurrar
as bolas para dentro então isso aí
pessoal espero que tenham gostado se
vocês quiserem ajudar o canal eu deixar
um leque e se inscrevam caso não seja um
script para acompanhar essas coisas que
eu faço estiverem sugestões do projeto é
só deixar nos comentários que o vanish e
tento fazer então e foi muito obrigado
até a próxima etapa ao i